this is one of our pride and joy it's
the outer 8,800 and it's commonly
referred to although argued it's the
first personal computer there were
machines that went before it it's
unquestionable but this one is
considered the first couple of reasons
firstly the quantities it's holding was
lots of an made they were Kip form you
could also buy ready-made as well the
most important thing about it is the two
strands of computing that is sort of
created in that Bill Gates saw this
machine and thought this is fantastic we
can write software for this it's not
very usable as it is we're going to
write a basic interpreter for it and
Microsoft was born on the other side of
the fence people like Steve Jobs well
not people like Steve Jobs Steve Jobs
actually saw this machine and and
thought well ok this is a start but it's
not the computer I want this I want a
machine that you could actually type on
and comes up on the screen that's where
I see it going and it spurred Steve Jobs
and Steve Wozniak into creating then
machines the Apple one and then the
Apple two and then everything else Apple
so it's a really really important
machine and a pivotal point in history
or from this one machine in 1975
it's an American machine made by a
company called mitts and these guys were
originally sort of producing sort of
telemetry systems remote control systems
and got that but they were having a very
hard time and the the guy behind MIT's
sort of decided that you know he had to
go to the bank and say oh I'm gonna need
some more money otherwise we're going to
hit the wall but I do have an idea for a
new product and it's a computer that you
can build and yeah
the it's all he might sell a few of them
but it ended up setting huge numbers of
them - it's a bunch of computer
enthusiasts basically and it actually
not so much computer enthusiasts they
weren't at that time their electronics
enthusiasts they didn't know they were
computers into us until this thing I hit
so yeah and it's all a lot more than you
expected and you know MIT's went on to
produce sort of this version and sort of
lighter versions as well but really did
inspire you know that generation into
hacking these things I'm making them do
I mean more than they were capable of at
the time and hence the computer industry
group
in its original configuration it was
really really rudimentary you had no
keyboard yet no screen
you had these switches on the bottom
here so you had access to the data bus
there and you could toggle in data and
read access to the address bus and you
could single step a load code into it
and the data is shown out on these lines
here so you programmed it in binary and
you've got your answers back in binary
you'd have the instruction set for the
the processor you could then look up the
op codes they would have a binary
representation you toggle those in steps
in the X location put the next up code
Ian it's you know very very rudimentary
machine code programming and as you've
got to know this machine and the the
opcode set for that processor you
started to remember these things and you
remembered the kind of the pattern more
than the actual the the numbers but you
remember those pairs you could toggle in
things reasonably quickly but still
hideously slow today sort of comparisons
so one of the first things that people
remember doing with it of any great sort
of sheikhs was toggling in some code
which is basically just a lot of delay
loops and guy called Steve Dompierre
took it to the homebrew club and set it
up on the on the table started toggling
in his code and ultimately it's great
vibrant gathered around him said write
gonna run the code and this sort of
program full of delay loops you know how
your cue function is food and you get
the buzzing noises when something's
going to ring you they used an FM radio
at the time the interference created by
the processor in the circuitry interfere
with the radio so the longer the delay
loop the lower the buzz was on the radio
and the short that I loop the higher the
buzz was so yeah doing that got it to
play the fall on the hill the old
Beatles tune at the time
[Music]
and people were you know that was
fantastic you know we've got this
committee to do something and this or
one of the early stories that sort of
came about from the the outer but it's a
really intriguing machine because of you
know these stories that are associated
with the people that were using it and
the stories of the homebrew club at that
time which you know created a whole
group of people that create machines
that change their lives is the big
reveal so this is the internals of our
serial number three and it's quite
drastically different it has a simple
circuit board inside just one circuit
board with all the components on and it
had this connector at the back which
allows you to increase it to a massive
16 K of memory with that rampant